the hottest new status symbol in silicon
valley is a subpoena in the twitter elon
lawsuit i think that wokeness is almost
religious movement the world in which we
all just blindly follow along that's
just it's gone the ship has sailed is
this why like donald trump and aoc are
the same person yes i refer to him as
the most sort of successful clown in
human history and i mean that like in a
almost a positive cruz was calling it
out way before everyone else and he was
right about everything
a couple of congresswoman or fake
handcuffs yes wikipedia is a
battleground just like the dictionaries
of battleground explain that the lab
league stuff the lab leak was that's the
craziest one the president united states
his son every time that he wants to hang
out with prostitutes do drugs uh pretty
much like just live his life puts like
17 cameras on his head all right guys
i'm here with mike uh i think a great
place to start is just what is a pirate
wire you have a publication called
pirate wires what the hell's a pirate
wire oh man uh so yeah power wires is my
media company um
a pirate wires is it's like i swear i
have it's
it's just sort of how i feel i guess on
the internet it's like the i kind of
conceive of the internet as this chaotic
turbulent ocean and you have kind of
like flagship empire uh
these like empire ships kind of
patrolling the seas um and it's just
like me kind of watching and sending
dispatches from the insanity so you're
like the somali pirate as the caribbean
pirate kirby okay caribbean fighter what
is the difference uh i think that the
caribbean pirates
it's like rum heavy um it's like hidden
gold on secret islands pirate coves in
beautiful locations is like very much
kind of the energy i'm trying to
represent not so much the somalia not
trying to like murder and pillage and
rape and uh yeah no it's like a more uh
you know it is too it's like the
caribbean pirates are
in the past and so we can look back on
it with rose-colored glasses and every
now and then they were great people they
were amazing they were they were heroes
also i mean pirates movies that's the
american pirate piracy it's like that's
like
a part of american history as well it's
like why do you say that well that's how
we used to handle that's how we used to
to take care of the british i mean this
was like a much more dominant power and
we used sort of pirate tactics to uh
navigate
a competitor with whom we really had no
business competing they were way bigger
way more powerful way wealthier and so
you kind of have to be a little bit
gorilla about it so america was
technically the insurgency i mean we
were i think that if you look in
hindsight it's obvious we were always
going to win it's like a resource game
it's the distance um
it is the commitment to all of those
things but at the time it seemed
impossible
and do you think uh as we've watched
the american history play out uh other
countries have been like oh you know
that american revolution thing like they
had certain tactics we should just
employ them or do you think that's us
just trying to be privileged people in
america looking at war after war after
war and trying to overlay them on top of
each other
i mean i think we had a huge impact on
the world what i lived uh i was an
english teacher in spain for a little
bit after college and one thing i
thought was really interesting was how
everyone in europe was like
they really believed the french
revolution happened before the american
revolution they genuinely believed this
why
no idea what like what happened over
there education wise but they all
they would all talk about this it's not
true obviously it's like the american
revolution happened first um and google
and i and i i had a college professor
also who used to go on and on about how
the american revolution wasn't a real
revolution and he talked about the
french revolution as being a real
revolution as like presenting
fundamental change and blah blah blah
blah uh but but of course it's all
[ __ ] the american revolution was
we had an intellectual revolution in
which we sort of
decided that the concept of
the divine monarch was
stupid he got rid of it completely
why did he inaudible rights of people
right there in in in the piece i guess
the idea is that like we we've a lot of
our our sort of concept of rights is
is derived from british law but um
but i mean the french concept of rights
as well it's it's we were the first
country that had a real revolution of
the people yeah why did he think the
french revolution was a real revolution
i think because
he sees
i mean his framing was that it was a
fundamentally
different government and perhaps ours
was not our ours was was was closer to
the parliament system or something i
don't know it's a lot of code man i
think that i think that mostly what
people want to do is
is
eat away at the idea that there's
something special about america and um
and it's silly because
that's the path for them to calamity i
mean there is something special about
america i don't actually think america
can be replicated anywhere else i don't
think i used to think it was just a
matter of philosophy there are people
like peter zaihan who think it's just a
matter of geography i think it's
somewhere in the middle but we are
special it's a we're we're a special
place we're we're protected by two
oceans we have two neighbors both of
them peaceful with us most of that does
come down to geography it's like a hard
place to invade from and into um we have
abundant natural resources we have
inherited uh a history of rights from
britain that we then kind of made more
libertarian and extremely pro-individual
and pro-freedom
and we have just an incredible amount of
capital that we're we're sort of riding
forward with we're in an amazing
position it is hard to replicate this
country we obviously just saw russia
invade ukraine i it's almost info uh
impossible to believe that mexico would
invade america or canada would invade
america right like it i don't even think
there's anyone who would say that with a
straight face and be like yes i think
this could happen well no and i mean
it's also it's i don't are there any
more there's no more peaceful border
than the canadian u.s border in the
world i think mexico yeah we have this
immigration problem but
even with that it's still not of a super
patrolled border i mean that's part of
the problem uh we have they're just we
have really we have really strong
relationships with both countries and
they're strong trade partners they are
ideologically very close to us um
especially canada obviously within the
anglosphere uh yeah there's just really
nothing like america the mexico border
is an interesting place to start to dive
into the insanity of the world obviously
donald trump who is going to build a
wall and
in some ways it was a proxy a simple
statement that just said hey we want
better border security yeah right but
build a wall is a much better meme uh it
really gets people jazzed up well i
think what i loved about it is
when you say
no to it
you have to you have to answer the
question of like well why why don't you
want why don't you want the the wall and
you either say because
it's not going to work
in which case you're admitting that we
need to stop this sort of like free flow
of illegal immigration from uh south
america or you say uh because i don't
believe in the concept and i mean the
entire left has really gotten to a place
the idea that we should have open
borders was a pretty radical idea that
was strongly libertarian it was not
leftist it was that i mean bernie
sanders was anti-immigration because of
labor uh libertarians were open borders
it was a koch brothers thing uh that has
completely changed the democratic party
has more or less
in rhetoric at least adopted the
language of libertarians on things like
immigration and then in practice it's
more complicated because i guess i mean
these sort of both major parties have
less of a hard time lying libertarians
to their detriment love to be sort of
principled and honest um no matter what
to a fault
why do you say that uh the democrats
have kind of almost taken over or
infiltrated the like open border
movement what is their argument i think
it like happened to them i think that
wokeness is like a pretty chaotic crazy
almost religious movement that i mean it
reminds me i don't know if you've ever
seen have you watched game of thrones
okay well there's uh this sort of evil
queen who i love name's cersei um i'm
not surprised you love game of thrones
she's an illegitimate ruler of of king's
landing uh and she has to fend off the
new young guns and to do this she
invokes a growing religion she goes to
the religious leader he's like this very
like uh austere like jesus looking kind
of guy no beard but like barefoot walks
around everywhere
pro poverty so like adam newman just a
couple centuries ago yes little little
shaved down a little more uh like a
little older shorter hair but very adam
numanesque um
and
uh she aligns with it because it's
powerful and she uses it to destroy her
enemies but then it it comes after her
and it's like no you're impure and it
just burns it sort of like burns that
world of power
down and uh i think that's what the
democrats did the average person is not
woke the average person i think looks at
this stuff and is like
this is crazy and regressive and um you
know why are we why are we reducing
people to things like their race and
gender it seems wrong it seems like the
opposite of everything that we
worked against for all these decades um
but it was powerful and young people
loved it and it was deranged and it felt
like you had the grassroots energy on
your side and so people tapped into it
and now it's consuming everything and if
you notice now really where wokeness is
striking is on the left it doesn't
people on the right i mean if you're
working for disney maybe you're going to
get canceled but the average person on
the if you're purely in politics you
have nothing to worry about if you're
media it's like maybe you get cancelled
but then you start a sub stack or you
work for someone who has who has their
own uh who has their own sort of budding
media company um the game is social
media and unless you get canceled on
social media you still have your
followers and in fact when people try to
cancel you and you say
[ __ ] off you just become more popular so
i mean unless you're like sort of left
of center let's go to this idea of like
the woke is uh equivalent of a religion
right so i think most people think of
that as like oh religion is declining in
america and uh there's now these like
ideologies that have replaced it or at
least tangentially kind of risen as
religion has declined um
but what you're making argument is less
about like the uh uh kind of the
congregation you're making the argument
that like no the politicians are the
priest
right like they're the ones who are
saying hey human nature is that you want
to party and have sex and like curse but
jesus in the bible says you shouldn't do
that and so like hold back on your
inhibitions right and like be a man or
woman of god
the
politicians essentially are the leaders
of the woke movement
are almost saying hey you all don't want
to view the world this way but like this
is the pure or uh ethical way to view
things right i mean first of all i don't
think the political leaders are actually
the priests i think that it's it's all
it's like academia is where it started
it's mostly professor oriented this is
why these people are also obsessed with
like forgiving college debt and getting
everybody into college even though it
increasingly is increasingly obvious
that the meme of if you go to college
you're going to do better than someone
who doesn't is is incorrect in in most
cases of uh of the liberal arts that are
so so you go and get a gender studies
degree um and you're now a hundred
thousand dollars in debt because you
went to a pretty good school but you
kind of like squeaked your way in is
that is that better than not going to
college and becoming a plumber of course
not it's just insane that doesn't make
any sense at all um
why the why are people so so determined
to get every kid in college
regardless of what they're studying um
regardless of how well it's setting them
up for their future they don't care
about that they just want them in the
machine because it's it's a it's a
religious indoctrination campus and
that's what it is now that's what all of
college is it's bled out and so now you
have it's like how do we appease the
academics in the first place but now
increasingly you have this sort of class
of activists these people who are and
social media allows this i mean you can
you can eke a living out of it um some
people are better than others sean king
is really good uh i don't know if you've
read about his 40 000 dog he just bought
with the funds from his activists tell
me about this guy because i i saw an
article one time and uh i have no clue
if this is true or not but let's just
dive right into the [ __ ] um
that they basically were like he
literally changed his appearance and
everything to like more alignment i am
not touching this but i mean we'll talk
about what the controversy is i mean
we're talking about a man who many
people think
is a white man pretending to be a black
man i don't
know
that that is something that i would say
i will say that black twitter loves to
tease him about it i mean he's uh we
could go online anytime there's a sean
king controversy it's it's usually it's
usually like black twitter that's that's
merciless um and this is because he's
gotten a lot of criticism from
especially black women for like stealing
funds and things like this so you just
google it this is not i'm not an expert
in the sean king discourse i'm sort of a
casual observer every now and then i dip
in but i mean uh they call them things
like talcum x and i mean there's like a
whole there's like a whole
litany of like insane things that they
say but he's really powerful um he's
really influential uh he i think
what was it maybe it was rihanna did
some kind of video with him not too long
ago and this is what always sets people
off or it's uh
it's other activists who are angry at
the opportunities that he's receiving um
so is it a level of uh jealousy envy
something like that i think part of it
is that to be fair
to sean king um which i hate doing i he
he is he does seem actually committed to
the cause of sort of
uh
he really believes in the like
police brutality stuff and
um that's i mean a big part of what he
talks about but he's gotten famous
because of it and he's made money off of
it and he gets incredible opportunities
because of it i think people see that as
in some way
[Music]
lacking integrity
because i mean to go back to our model
for religion is christianity and that is
austere and you know you're it's nothing
about the physical world matters you
everything you're doing is for the sort
of next world you're you're working
towards that and uh
and this is mapping to that in some way
and so if you're making a lot of money
and you're really successful and you've
got all these sort of like worldly
riches because of your sort of you know
you're like goodness then it's how good
is it really like i mean are you are you
really an activist or um or do you just
play one on is that the playbook now is
like drive a bunch of attention and then
figure out a way to monetize the
attention and we're watching this yeah
there's obviously the woke component uh
there's uh sean king there's also uh you
can go through the uh the right you can
go through kind of all the different
causes and like there seems to be uh if
you throw out an issue we could all
think of like the one person on social
media who's like hung their hat on that
thing yeah and ends up building up a
huge audience and then like figures out
a way to monetize it i think it's like
i don't even think people
realize what they're doing online i mean
it's a really chaotic place because of
the incentives and the incentives on
social media are all they're all towards
either the novelty or the extreme
because that's what drives attention you
want to get attention you want likes and
clicks you know retweets you want
followers
and the way that you get that spotlight
is by doing something that no one else
is doing
um i think the average person i think
most people myself included
you live on these platforms and over
time you kind of internalize the rules
you you have a sense of them you can
feel it like when a tweet's not doing
well immediately you you have a well if
you have enough followers and you you
have a kind of expectation of a certain
kind of engagement you can feel pretty
much within the first minute whether or
not something is working or not and at
that point i think that it's just uh
behavioral therapy basis how behavior
therapy works is positive reinforcement
when you don't get that hit um
you
you discard that tactic and when you do
get that positive hit you
uh you keep up with that tactic you dig
in deeper stronger it takes a lot to
guard against that kind of stuff and to
try and be honest with yourself and to
say the things that you want to say with
your platform um most people
aren't even thinking about this stuff
they're just naturally sort of guided
it's like this is very it's marshall
mclaren talking about the medium as the
message like the medium that we exist
inside of shapes the kinds of stuff that
we talk about uh the way that we talk
about the things that we talk about the
way that we talk about them this is is
very much i think what we're seeing on
all across social media and every
platform is is going to be a little bit
different um whether it's short form
words or video or whatever else they all
have their own rules and so naturally
you're going to see a certain kind of
content in each
and uh with the activists for sure i
think that's what's happening i think
that people are gravitating towards the
extreme because
that is what's rewarded or or the the
the extreme the bizarre um the sort of
uh the controversial um
all of those things
is this why like donald trump and aoc
are the same person yes right like they
they let they employ the same tactics
they're on two different institutions
they live on uh i wouldn't say i don't
really see donald trump as
classically
ultra right i mean people like to call
him a fascist he was a democrat and he
said that if yeah i don't run as a
republican i see him as more
like i see aoc on the far left for sure
um i see
i see trump as an outlier
kind of i once referred to rights that
raptor the january 6th i refer to him as
the
the most uh sort of successful clown in
human history and i mean that like in a
almost a positive sense like i think
that he is
is the court jester and he
he did the clownish most clownish thing
possible which is he won the presidency
and then we had the clown on the throne
throwing eggs at the court for four
years and it was it was crazy he was
entertaining as [ __ ] and it threw the
did what a clown is supposed to do he
threw the curtain back and we saw how
things really worked and he threw the
curtain back at
of power he threw the curtain of power
backwards we saw the the machinery um
behind it all
and uh and then he laughed and and we
laughed and
um and is this why like the reason why i
say so it was so entertaining was
regardless of you right left independent
anywhere in between uh even the media
companies like they literally could not
look away it was just absolutely it was
the greatest show on earth yeah if you
put donald trump's name in a headline
viral well he's an entertainer and so of
course
of course america i mean given the
mediums that are dominant would
ultimately
elect a really
sort of savant level entertainer donald
trump has an intuitive sense of crowds
he is funny i think that this is one of
the biggest mistakes democrats made was
they would they would meet him he would
say something
um and they would be like he's so angry
he's filled with so much hate
and it's just obviously not true he's
laughing all the time he's he's having
fun and and if you can't
if you can't acknowledge that he's
telling jokes and that they're they're
landing then you can't fight with him
because he's playing a different game
than you are you have to be at least as
funny as you have to at least have a
sense of humor or you're just never
going to survive in in a fight with
trump yeah uh scott adams wrote a whole
book and he basically talks about the
two moments uh that everyone should have
known like hey this is over uh was one
uh on the um
kind of logo uh or uh the mantra mission
whatever you want to call it uh
supposedly hillary clinton ran like 100
plus tests on what it was her uh slogan
gonna be and sort of ended up coming
together like stronger together right
which like very politician whatever uh
and i'm sure that they ran the test and
they got the data and they're like okay
this is this is it and then the way the
story is told is that supposedly trump
just walks in a room like hey we need a
slogan he was like uh make america great
again yeah right and you know obviously
borrowed it from the past or whatever
but like intuition is you know kind of
the the the take away from that story of
like he really understood kind of what
would play and then the second one was
uh in the debate i think it's megyn
kelly uh who is uh uh asking questions
and uh said something about you know
you've previously called women xyz
whatever and he's like nope only rosie
o'donnell and like again to your point
scott basically lays out the argument
he's like it's a lose-lose if you lean
into it you're an [ __ ] you're a
misogynist you're like all this stuff if
you back away you're weak you're like
whatever it's like a very very smart
question to ask him because it basically
was lose lose
he sidestepped it right in a way that
only an entertainer probably could do it
i think a lot of what people reacted to
with trump was just it was how he said
things and it was it was they clocked
him as fundamentally unserious
in competition for what they perceived
as the most serious uh institute of
power in on the planet and um and that's
actually what drove them crazy it wasn't
any of his positions it wasn't um
it wasn't his lack of respect for them
or anything else it was it was that he
was jarring it was like uh he can't have
this someone like him can't be here it
challenges their entire worldview a
challenge there it challenged my
worldview um
i
was
i mean i'd be lying if i said i thought
he was going to win i thought it was
impossible myself i'm not
for me i wasn't like
i found the whole election pretty
disorienting that was the beginning i
think of 2016. well 2015 is when it all
kind of began and then 2016 for sure is
like when the world felt
it this was in this period of time where
sort of like every year felt crazier and
crazier until 2020 and then we got a
pandemic and like a race war it was like
insane it was built and built and built
and built but that was the beginning of
the
sort of unraveling of the kind of like
20th century america like 90s america
the early 2000s america even after
september 11th there was this
sense that history was gonna
if the future was going to look like
this forever it was going to be this
very static suburban type american world
and everything was going to be basically
the same and then everything started
changing and and i was
i it
even while predicting that things were
going to change i somehow wasn't
prepared to to see them start yeah start
changing i have this theory uh i can't
put a date like there's no like hey it
was you know august 1st or whatever um
but somewhere around that time frame uh
my belief is that that's when america
went online this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine i sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod three you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself innate sleep you can
go to
8sleep.com today to go ahead and get 150
off your order 8sleep.com
not only do i sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and i begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep it's the
first it's like okay the transition
happened we're like yes the internet was
built before in the you know 15 20 years
beforehand and we were laying the
infrastructure consumer behaviors were
changing companies were being built like
all the stuff but somewhere in the mid
2010s 14 15 16 somewhere in there yeah
it was like oh [ __ ] the internet matters
more it was mobile administration yeah
it was everyone had an iphone and so
everyone now was walking around with the
internet yes and that was you know you
might have dipped in before and checked
your email but now you're living inside
of it and so the rules of the internet
begin to shape the way that you think
about the world donald trump was the
first twitter pres he was twitter he is
twitter is the reason that he's the
president correct and um aoc is in the
same it's the same exact mold these are
social media candidates and we are a
social media country um you know people
spend hours a day on social media in
america i think it's like 200 million
plus people uh on faith probably more at
this point on facebook i just saw that
tick tock was at 100 million um people
were spending on tick tock like two to
three maybe four hours a day
it's facebook two hours a day instagram
two hours a day like youtube two hours a
day that's
that is our
that is our reality
to a certain extent zuckerberg talks
about meta a lot and it's kind of weird
it seems to change the name of your
company
to
be
uh
a thing that doesn't yet exist right
like you you have this very successful
company now you're saying we're meta now
meta is the meta it's a reference to the
metaverse a virtual reality uh world of
virtual reality that we're going to kind
of go into with our oculus rifts and
walk around and it's very reminiscent of
it's literally from uh snow crash
and
uh
the idea
of that
of kind of
changing everything to be a thing that
doesn't exist changing your whole your
your whole brand
to to
to be the metaverse it seems weird until
you sort of reflect and realize that
we're already living in it we're already
there that's it it's just it's a less
it's not a it's a less perfect version
of it it doesn't look the way that it
looked like in sci-fi movies but um
but yeah we're there i mean we're all
even with dating right like we're
we're all the idea of like are you
dating online everyone's dating online
whether or not they're on the apps
because you meet someone and you google
them and you go to their social media
presence and you and you you're sort of
you're
you're dating online that it's like it's
a very it's changed every every aspect
of human culture this has changed
imagine a 1990s movie where they were
like you know tom cruise sitting there
with his gl with his gloves on and he
was swiping through women
right and like oh no this one this is
the one that i want to talk to like
people be like uh i don't know is this
okay to like publish right and now every
single person does that on their phone
every single day who's looking for
someone in a city yeah it's why we it's
funny that that still somehow is not
making it into our movies and television
we don't
we don't like the way that it looks
and that's
weird i don't know that we've ever seen
something like that i think about the
way that uh when you dream
no one dreams of their iphone
that doesn't seem like why that's crazy
for something that you walk around with
every day and think about and if you're
missing it for a minute you're like [ __ ]
where's my phone i lost my phone you
panic a little bit because you're
addicted to it um why isn't it in our
dreams that's just it's like very
that i don't have an answer for that's
just a question why do you think it's
not there i have no idea i have
absolutely no idea it's a bizarre
i don't understand that um
i do think that people
feel
a little bit trapped by this stuff
younger people especially who spend more
of their time on it
but
they seem screwed to me like i i grew up
i think we're about the same age i grew
up and like people started getting cell
phones in high school yeah right and uh
my mom was like very much hey you're
going to get one later than everyone
else's back when cell phones were just
cell phones they were just phones like
the razer yeah
huge text as well huge deal when
somebody got the razor right like gosh
whatever and then the sidekick you could
slide it open and there's like no keys
that snake on it
right so there's like three or four
phones that if you grew up in this
general time frame like once everyone
got one it was like cool thing uh
but like you texted barely because it
was t9 so you had to like click through
everything and painting the ass uh and
you made phone calls and like that was
it but if we grew up and like every time
you did anything in high school and even
in college and everyone whipped out
their phone like they were the paparazzi
like it'd be a lot more people i
remember when i was in high school a kid
created a message board for
it was we there were three high schools
in my town and this kid at one of our
rival high schools created a message
board for all of the local high schools
where
kids could go and
and just talk to each other
and it created such tremendous drama
that
they
i don't even know how this is legal but
they forced him to shut it down and
it was just it was like i mean this
we're talking about like months and
months and months to build up uh a
dramatic build up before finally it
ended and and now we live in a world
where that's just
it consumes you can't shut it down
that's how we live well you think like
how early kids get cell phones now if
you're 12 14 years old and you get a
cell phone you're on tick tock and
you're on instagram it's like you're
screwed
right like your entire view of the world
i keep looking for i mean there have to
be there are trade-offs always it seems
in technology i i think that what i was
not prepared for something that i was
wrong about
um
when social media first
bubbled up i was like i was very much a
tech a blind tech op not blind but
i thought everything was better
everything was getting better everything
was better than it was everything was
getting better um i had no
i just didn't i thought that that all
warnings of social media and whatnot i
thought it was all just
um
propaganda
anti-anti-business anti-tech propaganda
um none of the predictions were right
they were they were all like it's gonna
it's terrible in ways that and it's not
that was not right but there were
negative externalities and there are
negative externalities probably in every
technological development
um you think it changes people's brain
chemistry i think that
when you change the reward structure in
your life it's changing you're it's
changing you fundamentally yeah you're
definitely changing um i don't know if
it like physically changes your brain
i'm not a not a brain guy but um you
gotta bring in a neuroscientist i think
for this conversation you don't have to
be a brain guy but i know that cruz was
calling it out way before everyone else
and he was right about everything
this is it this is i mean this is tom
cruise is really i wrote about this
empire this is so in a a piece called um
dark plots and secret explanations in uh
empire wires
i
wrote about tom cruise i this is how i
this is like part of my processes um you
know i'm sort of
we used to say surf the web it was such
a great phrase and that that is kind of
i'm out there
the equivalent of caribbean pirate
versus somali prior right is like you
can go on the internet or you could surf
the webs yeah yeah i'm surfing i'm
cruising i'm on my little i'm on my
pirate ship just like chilling out like
like laughing looking at all the
insanity and then every now and then um
something
happens that
feels like it
represents a lot more
and
tom cruise in 2005
um
appeared on the today show to talk about
war of the worlds
which
i just assumed bombed no it was one of
the most popular movies ever it was his
most popular movie until for the last 15
years huge box office success
um until now until uh the newest uh
top gun movie um
2005 he appears on the today show with
matt lauer and this is in this sort of
moment in which he's been framed as
pretty crazy
by the media and america i mean i
thought he would everyone thought he was
crazy scientology i think it was yeah i
was in college and i mean talking about
crazy tom cruise was the thing that
people did yeah scientology was there
but also
he uh he had just a month prior to this
interview with matt lauer he jumped up
on a couch on the oprah show and talked
about how much he loved katie holmes
and in hindsight i look back i'm like i
watched the interview and it just looks
like he's being like a crazy
actor guy i i didn't it doesn't seem
unhinged to me i mean i think i think
part of that's because there's so much
unhinged behavior around us now that i
look back at that and i'm like that's
just a guy that's just that's what
that's just what they do that's just
like how we all do it now um but
he is in he's on a sort of like tour of
crazy and uh so he goes on the today
show he talks about world of the worlds
for like five minutes and matt lauer is
like cool so you you said i forget the
actress's name
um you sort of criticized her for being
on antidepressant medicine
and um
that's messed up they like respond
before the nation the entire nation
which is wild that's what they used to
do right like crazy what do you think
yeah yeah like you're here i mean that's
even to this day i mean it's always
your movie or your book is just an
excuse to get you
on the show and then it's like now tell
me about your personal life but tom
cruise's personal life was a little more
interesting at that point because of the
scientology stuff because of his new
bride was she like coerced into marrying
him i mean there are all sorts of crazy
rumors um and he had these really
extreme views about
psychology
or psychiatry uh which is that it is
pseudoscientific [ __ ]
um and he just said you know
there is absolutely no scientific
evidence
um
supporting the notion that depression is
caused the root of depression is a
chemical imbalance in the brain
um which at the time was accepted
scientifically here's the thing
it wasn't okay like everyone said that
and that was the accepted thing it was
you are crazy how dare you say this
unbelievable but
what just happened so this this
interview resurfaced where he in which
he says you know there's no evidence for
this uh and then i mean there are
endless articles about how crazy is how
dangerous this was um
study comes out an umbrella review of
all of the studies on this subject over
the last you know several decades and
what it concludes is not that depression
isn't caused
by a chemical imbalance the brain we
don't know what causes depression what
what the conclusion that we have is that
there's no evidence for that and there
hasn't ever been and that's it was a
huge deal everyone was like wait a
minute tom cruise clip resurfaces from
15 years ago 17 years ago
and suddenly we have this weird
conversation about
experts and what i thought i mean this
is my this is my jam i love to write
about this kind of stuff in the
contemporary world like i love to talk
about when the experts are wrong and
some random [ __ ] on reddit was right
um
but this
struck me as different because the
conversation on looking back i
remembered it as
being crazy i remembered him seeming
crazy and rude and it was like this wild
thing
if you watch the interview now it's
so calm and normal and tom is definitely
like
you need to educate yourself to matt
lauer which is accurate um but he wasn't
crazy he wasn't yelling he he he wasn't
uh he wasn't saying anything that was
completely untethered from reality it
was a very regular sort of conversation
about
studies that he had read
and um
and was shocking to me to realize
the treatment of him back then as
compared to the world we live in now
because we have to sense that the entire
world is like uniquely hostile to
dissent you know everyone's constantly
talking about cancer culture i myself am
talking about this kind of stuff
you know uh there's all this sort of
pressure from the establishment to
silence the voices of dissent uh they're
using social media platforms to do this
i believe that all of this is true but
culturally actually
things are much more open to dissent now
than they were 17 years ago um i just
didn't
i didn't realize that the culture has
changed uh in a huge way and
the tom cruises of the world are now
yeah completely normalized there are any
number of them this is sort of that this
is sort of yeah uh
the the legacy of tom cruise
i've seen
i've seen uh brett weinstein a couple of
other folks kind of talk uh in certain
situations with like look a lot of the
scientific studies or the consensus view
and maybe even like the virtue signaling
that comes out of some of those
communities uh a lot of times it's based
on like hey we ran some studies and uh
we don't know what the answer is like it
must be this other thing it must be a
chemical imbalance in the brain right
yes we don't have evidence but like
we've tried all these other things like
what else could it be but also just so
the so the drugs do seem to i don't want
to say that the drugs don't work right
like like it does seem for many people
the drugs do help um
the drugs are a chemical and so you must
be missing some chemical or something
right it's like yeah you just it's a
process of elimination without the
actual confirmation of a
of a scientific study that proves yes
this is true i think we also just
have this really wrong belief
that we know everything we even know
most things the idea that you go into
the doctor and the doctor is just going
to know what's wrong with you you
internalize that as little kid as like
that's the way the world works we know
most things we have medicine and you
take a pill and then your bad thing goes
away and i mean as i've gotten older i
don't mind you but like i've been to the
doctor a couple of times but they don't
know what's wrong with me it's not a
huge thing but it's like this is
disorienting what do you mean you don't
know uh and then i even had one case
where we tried a few different drugs and
like nothing really worked and multiple
tests multiple doctors and you know i'm
fine now this was years ago but
that was a
a really
shocking moment for me
it it was like yeah again i irrationally
i understand that
these people are not gods and uh there
are lots of things that they don't know
and they're not perfect there are lots
of things that we as people don't know
but emotionally i think i'm still
carrying that sort of childhood sense of
of like these are the people in charge
and they know stuff and they're the good
ones and we have to listen to them like
that's still in my gut and it's hard to
shake um and you have to shake it
because it's not true like there are all
sorts of things that we don't know i
would say we don't know most things and
i mean i was at a doctor a couple of
years ago where
he was trying to figure out what i had
i suggested something and he was like
hmm i've never actually uh i've never
seen that before i'm gonna do some
research and get back to you and i'm
like do you mean like like you're gonna
google it
and he said yes
i was like what that's
crazy why am i here it was it was just
insane to me um but that's that's you
know that's most experts
uh my brother uh is a doctor and so i've
seen him and kind of his classmates and
everything over the years go through the
process and uh my brother's obviously
incredibly intelligent um
and i always ask him as a gut check on
like the health care system like hey
evaluate like people you come in contact
with and like the hospitals or the
doctors or whatever and he's like well
it's like everything you know like
there's some
incredibly intelligent like i trust them
with my life there's other people you
couldn't pay me to go see them right and
so like you get the dispersion and i
think this is where you end up uh even
if you look like here in miami like um
uh there's certain health care
facilities and people are like this is
amazing right like everyone should go
here and there's other ones where
literally it's like oh everyone that
goes or dies
right
and like when you think about you're
like holy [ __ ]
but that's not unique to any geography
like if you go to especially in small
towns yeah if you go like people are
just they don't have confidence right
it's because of these experiences where
they're talking to a doctor and doctor
doesn't know the answer or they believe
that something uh there's medical
treatment and uh there was wrong
decisions made and there was a bad
outcome whether it's you know
unfortunately death or you know
something less severe but you start
realizing you're like
nobody it's not that nobody knows
nothing it's just that like
the level of expertise that we assign in
many different fields is nowhere near
what in our minds we hope it is yeah and
i think the big difference between today
and 20 years ago is now people are just
logging onto the internet and disproving
things that the experts are telling them
and i think what you're saying is right
there are people who are just very smart
and very competent and probably should
be in charge great love it would love
for them to actually be in charge the
problem is that we're a huge country and
we need a lot of doctors and we need a
lot of uh government officials and we
need a lot of uh you know people working
in business or what i mean every every
sort of
aspect of the society you know you need
a lot of people um
most people are not that good and so
you're gonna have a lot of experiences
with people who who suck and every time
you do and then you go and you prove
that they're wrong yourself
it chips away at this idea that there
are people in charge and
that they are good and that
makes you feel sort of ungrounded like
untethered to the world like you feel
nervous like you're living in a world of
chaos that is i think it's a very
internet kind of phenomena um
there was this ap article that came out
dark plots it was uh what was it it was
like
it was just like more americans are
believing in conspiracy theories dark
plots and secret explanations and they
go into this
very his sort of breathless
warning about what's going on and uh
they say you know like more than ever
americans are turning away from
scientific experts and government
officials and the media and and
basically they're turning to the
internet to talk to these like crackpot
crazy alex jones types people um well in
the first place like alex jones
has been wrong about stuff but he's also
been right about some stuff and
eventually america's gonna have to deal
with that um in the second
what i was more interested in
was this concept they can't let go of
which is that they are in some way
deserving of
authority
after years of proving that they are not
um
that
that
is over the world in which we all just
blindly follow along with the hegemony
of the sort of like hegemonic media
powers
that's just it's gone the ship has
sailed
what's going to happen increasingly is
people are going to be
interested in looking for
single individuals who
they trust to help them make sense of
the chaos and uh this is the success of
joe rogan this is like really what he
does is he's fun he people connect with
him personally and then he's sort of
on
air uh fact-checking things and and and
sort of navigating complicated topics
that are interesting um with a guest and
he's sort of like getting to the bottom
of stuff which is how we all feel it's
every scary thing that happens in the
world uh that actually affects our lives
so coveted was a great example of this
where you have to get to the bottom of
it and you can't trust the people who
are telling you [ __ ] because you keep
catching them in lies so where do you go
and you go to the internet and you start
googling around and you find some crazy
person who's telling you it's like a
microchip um
of the vaccines of microchip by bill
gates or whatever and then you talk you
see someone who's maybe like okay it's
probably not a microchip but here's what
the studies that i've read and here's
what i think and um i mean that's that's
the future we're gonna we're gonna be
finding for better or worse i'm not
saying this is better uh this is just
this is the world that we're heading
towards i'm writing a piece right now
i'm gonna publish it before this comes
out uh i'm pretty sure um called digital
osmosis theory and the entire idea is
that in the analog world we trusted
institutions and experts and when we
moved online there was literally osmosis
like we went from high density of where
we perceived knowledge and
kind of value and it has migrated and
transitioned to now this decentralized
internet of information where if you
have a topic whether it's covid or
anything else and you ask the average
american do you trust
the institution or do you trust what you
can find on the internet more and more
people are picking the internet over the
institution and some of it is because
over time they've lost
faith or trust because they've seen the
mistakes but also the amount of value
and quality on the internet has
skyrocketed because now all of a sudden
i don't know during govid like there are
a lot of people on there i was like oh
you're the head of you know
viral studies at whatever university
like
i like the fact that i can read what you
think right rather than have somebody
else try to just publish it in the new
york times all of
the answers
that we actually that people that we
have like every true thing that exists
that is known and exists
is online
the problem is just navigating all of
that information there's too much of it
we haven't we have an
overwhelming amount of information that
you'll never be able to navigate and
most of it is just
crazy um like made-up stuff and uh
just political uh everyone and there's
propaganda everywhere everyone does it i
think without even realizing it people
sort of spin things and
frame things in certain ways that end up
being misleading
so the problem is search and
i don't there's no technological tool
right now to help us with this and so
people are just going to fall back on
what they've done for thousands of years
which is they ask the person who seems
to like care the most about the news
what's going on that's like always what
it is even in elections this has always
been the case in our lives there's like
one person
or two in a friend group that are
actually paying attention and come
election time everyone's like yo so uh
who are we voting for what's going on
what like what should i care about i get
this all the time like in san francisco
for local politics i am that friend
people uh come to me and it's i'm like
yeah here's everything that i think um
but here's what you should read also
like i mean here's where the people are
talking about it here's where these
dramas are happening but people don't
they don't pay attention i don't blame
them it's a nightmare way to live um
being so like super plugged in when we
were kids uh and growing up uh there's a
lot of like scary things online or
whatever you would like find a headline
somewhere like wow that's kind of crazy
whatever now i don't think that we're
really that shocked by the headlines
because it's kind of uh we've seen so
many shocking headlines like you know
trump tweeted at uh um uh the north
korean uh government essentially and was
like literally like little rocket man
yeah right and like again going back to
like this like almost you can't believe
is real but here we are um
but now what i find the scariest or like
the most shocking is not the headlines
it's like when you go read the source
material
because one of two things happens if you
read the source material you're like
whoa this is a ridiculously big deal
like i can't believe they said you know
abc whatever or
it's you read the source material and
you look back at the headline and you're
like it's mostly that like like how did
this headline come out of this piece of
social media it's mostly like a weird
study of 10 if it's a medical thing it's
like you know 60 people
were studied and it's not conclusive and
the headlines like you know diabetes is
caused by rare fungus found on french
fries from mcdonald's or something
insane and it's like it's not accurate
is is accurate it's like just accurate
enough to not be sued in america which
in a con which is a country where it is
like famously difficult to be sued for
saying stupid [ __ ] um like that's that's
the kind of media dynamic there's a
thing in the uh in the bitcoin community
um there's a study uh that happened in
nigeria it's self-reported and they
surveyed i think it's like a thousand
four thousand uh nigerians uh and they
asked them how many of you have used or
hold bitcoin or cryptocurrencies and the
claim of the study is 32 of nigerians
use crypto
and so like
it doesn't take that long to quickly
figure out okay there's like 200 plus
million people in nigeria yeah it's
growing at a pace where by 2050 there'd
be more nigerians than americans and so
that's like a big number you don't have
to be a mathematician right you just
want tens of millions of people and then
you look and you're like but the
estimate is that there's like 150
million people globally that use the
technologies and you're like so a third
of all the people are nigerians higher
nigerian like
something seems off and i'm gonna go
with the sampling of a thousand to four
thousand people yeah as like the the
error here uh and so like by the way
like directionally is probably correct
right so you can say like okay there's
high internet penetration mobile phone
penetration like they have a failing
currency like yes it probably does have
a higher than normal uh penetration use
of the technology
i wouldn't hang my hat on the 32 being
like the number and it feels like if
that's happening in a study that frankly
doesn't really matter in the grand
scheme of like your health my health uh
the way we live our lives whatever like
what's happening in like the medical
environment what's happening in these
other areas i think so
this what process that you're going
through right here i mean this is
anytime that you want to understand
something this is the way that you do it
and it's usually like you talk to a
friend about it you read the headline
you dig in a little bit my friend uh uh
and colleague aaron gleason at founder's
function she runs pr like we always are
talking about stories together and it's
like
back in the day there were the diversity
studies and it was it was stuff like um
that had to do with uh
uh
disparity in in gender pay and things
like this and and so the article would
would come out with some like really
wild headline about women making like
like 30 less than men or something and
you'd be like wait like what what
actually is happening here and that's
when we both got in the habit of really
this was like back in 2017 when i think
uh me too was happening and um
just clicking into every single study
reading exactly what people were talking
about but that that process
is increasingly normalized across
across the culture it's like you have
two options either be a detective
or
just don't know what's going on and i
think a lot of people are fine
most people are fine just not know it's
not knowing uh what's going on but they
do want to know someone who's a
detective and they want to be able to
dip in uh or do they want to be able to
check in with that person and be like
hey
did you see this crazy headline that
can't be real is that real um and then i
detected put down a little detective hat
and
answers the questions for them but but i
think like so there's some topics for
sure right san francisco politics is
perfect example like it's a thing that
people in san francisco really care
about maybe there's some other folks who
are like you see san francisco as like
uh the city on the hill for woke
politics and like does this experiment
work or not or whatever and so like
there's some group of people who care
but like in the grand scheme of the
seven plus billion people in the world
like nobody really cares right so
you from a time investment standpoint uh
you do want to have that friend right
but then there's like
what i'll call the normalization of like
the conspiracy theories right that's now
entering the mainstream conversation and
so uh let's use the other administration
uh the white house uh recently came out
and was like a recession is not two
quarters of negative gdp growth yeah and
you're like
okay
uh i don't think that's right but let me
go to the internet right and kind of you
start the detective process and what you
find is like there was uh uh the first
question i had was like okay cool what
is the definition yeah and then the
answer was basically like oh there's
like this organization uh the national
bureau of economic research you're like
sounds made up but okay uh and they're
like and they just tell us when there's
a recess
and you're like well what's their
criteria right and then it's like well
we look at a confluence of factors and
vibes lists like 20 different things and
they're like it's fives yeah and then we
just like we'll tell you when there's a
recession and you're like
okay so like basically the definition of
a recession is no longer two consecutive
negative gdp quarters it's now like when
these people say it's a recession it's a
recession
okay who works there right like like you
start like going down and you like end
up in a real bad place very quickly and
like the trust in institutions like
falls off a cliff but you're like all
right fine whatever
whether it's labeled a recession or not
at the end of the day like small
businesses big businesses investors
consumers whatever they're going to like
act how they psychologically feel the
the economy so kind of vibes right
but then they go on national television
and they're like not only is it not a
recession but like it's never been a
recession yeah right and like they like
double and triple and quadruple down and
like
just some journalists credit like some
people are like uh
i have a question
right and they ask other journalists are
just like oh we're actually just pr like
we're just going to regurgitate the
state talking points whatever
but then you get on twitter
and twitter is uh
the super bowl of internet detectives oh
yeah what's war it's information the
whole culture is information war but
twitter is
it twitter's the arena where it's the
colosseum yeah that's where the combat
takes place
and so of course you get in and like you
kind of log in and you're just like i'm
not gonna type in recession in the
search bar not gonna do it not gonna do
it five minutes later i'm definitely not
gonna do it ten minutes [ __ ] it and you
type it in and you go and the very first
thing i see just like going absolute
mega viral is like 38 wikipedia entry
updates to the recession page and now
it's locked yeah and you're like
that could be a whole bunch of different
things that are going on there but like
that's in the last two days since these
talking points came out well yeah it's
war i mean wikipedia is a battleground
just like the dictionary is a
battleground um explain that i mean you
literally you have the dictionary
literally changing the definitions for
words in the middle of hotly debated uh
sort of concepts
in in the country so uh famously amy
comey barrett um
in her court hearing her congressional
hearing before she was nominated or
before she was
put on the court back when she was
nominated um she used the phrase sexual
preference
and
immediately a journalist
uh for i think huffington post i forget
where he works i always see his face
floating around the internet um he's
like this is you know
outrageous this is a huge insult it's
not a preference it's like blah blah
blah blah this is outdated offensive
language
um
i'm gay and i did not know it was
offensive i was like uh this is news to
me i've never heard that before i've
definitely heard people use the phrase
sexual preference up to
you know like the last week probably
like i mean
less than maybe i used to but it's it's
not it's not we're not dropping you know
a slur here this is like a phrase that
is said um
huge debate because
one of the the congressmen uh
then
brings us into the hearing and is like
you just said something extremely
offensive um apologize basically uh
there it does and then merriam-webster's
dictionary changes the definition of
sexual preference and includes
now it says you know this is an
offensive piece of this is now it's now
an uh offensive thing to say um so
any conversation about you know did she
or did she not say something offensive
it just it's like well let's let's look
at the dictionary what does the
dictionary have to say and the
dictionary says um well the dictionary
says that it votes for democrats
obviously that's i mean i i don't like
and this is
i wrote about this at the time i was
like i don't like knowing what political
party my dictionary votes for
and that is how wikipedia is as well
it's like these are battlegrounds now
for concepts but there are lots of words
and definitions that have changed over
the last two years it's like sexual
preference preference uh female vaccine
anti-vaxxer anti-vaxxer was a crazy one
because
anti-the definition of anti-vaxxer
changed from someone who
doesn't take vaccines who thinks all
vaccines are bad whatever to someone who
doesn't want a vaccine mandate was
included in in anti-vaxxer suddenly the
definition changed in such a way as a as
a thing that i thought was stupid my
whole life i suddenly was i was suddenly
the definition of an anti-vaxxer um
and that's the landscape that's the
terrain is the the place where we go for
source material if it's if it's i mean
doesn't matter who controls it if it's
controlled by an organization or if it's
or if it's crowdsourced
all of it is part of
of an information where we don't have
analog encyclopedias anymore we don't
have analog dictionaries there's no
there's no like
trusted
unchanging source that we can go to
people say bitcoin fixes this i'm
waiting for the solution i would love to
see it haven't seen it yet um right now
we're living in a world of malleable
information that is manipulated for
obvious political intent like constantly
every day um
it's just it's literally an information
war and the ground is sort of shifting
underneath our feet i tweeted um
something to the effect of like you
should be fearful when they try to
nationalize the dictionary
and like i i tweet a lot of things
that was like uh off the dome just you
know type it send it whatever uh
i've probably haven't gotten more text
messages about a tweet than that one in
a long time and i was just like why do
y'all care so like duh right like of
course and it was people being like
they're not nationalizing the dictionary
it wasn't people being like
okay yes i agree like we should be
fearful of that it was immediately
jumping to the like are they doing it or
not and i was like you guys already lost
like if we're already having the debate
like are they doing it or not
is basically proving the point i mean
there's no what my question is what's
the difference i mean the dictionary
already works for the state it already
works for the establishment this is you
have a few people who agree with the
political consensus and they're in
charge of the dictionaries that's just
what it is and they're going to change
online forever i mean i have at home
hardbound like a hard copy dictionary
and encyclopedia uh they don't make them
anymore so it's old it's like boomer
it's like 2 000 and i bought it on i
mean i bought it a few years ago i
bought it during uh the amy comey coney
bear thing like i
i that shook me i was like no no sir
i need an encyclopedia and it's i like
that it's dated pre
media penetration it's like it's like in
the matrix where they just choose 1999
as the year that like that was the last
or the late 90s they were like that's
that's when everything went downhill
after that it got super technological
and everything fell apart um and so they
just simulate that world forever i'm now
living in that it's like a an
information simulation of just before
the chaos began i mean the truth is i
still get most of my information online
yeah but i've got the encyclopedia there
uh if i'm really confused and you can
look back and just see
how things are changing it's basically a
snapshot of how people use words and
definitions and then you can see how far
we stray from sure and language changes
of course it it always changes it has
always changed especially the english
language is an especially
malleable
language it it incorporates a lot
what's different is the speed at which
things are changing because it's now
happening just in real time on a whim
based on a court hearing that a bunch of
democrats want to use as a weapon
and that's [ __ ] up and um it's gonna
get worse
let's talk about this idea of like i'm
offended right so uh you could have an
entire group of people that could be
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions of people and it seems like now
we live in a society where if one person
in that group says that they're offended
by something it becomes truth like
if one person says
sexual preference is offensive
everyone else is just like one guardian
writer just said that the word spazz was
offensive and beyonce had to change her
song that's crazy to me i looked at her
profile she's this uh she's a disabled
writer on discipline she writes about
disabilities um and she had like a
couple thousand followers and i was like
today this woman
is more powerful than beyonce
because she was offended yeah it's wild
but also
all beyonce had to say was
i'm not changing the song [ __ ] and
everyone would have been fine with it so
i mean at the end of the day it's like
it's it's in your hands like like do the
offended people really have this much
power or or are most people just cowards
do you think the playbook when
somebody goes after like the canceled
culture will use that as a generalized
term when canceled culture comes for
somebody the playbook now has been
pioneered whether it was by the trumps
of the world uh people on social media
uh it's just
no
just like literally like just stand your
ground say no and they go away yeah i
think it certainly is like i was saying
earlier i think it's like anyone
whose
it becomes a it becomes hard when
people who are more inclined to if being
offended are
in your sort of
they're part of your fan base
um
and
that's not a problem that i have and so
on either and so i don't worry about it
uh but if you are
ocasio-cortez
you should worry about it you know if
you're
if you're an entertainer
um
or a singer with a ton of young people
on tick-tock who are obsessed with the
the language of offense then it's going
to be a more challenging
equation for you to figure out uh i do
think that
well listen culture is
is changed and this is something that
i'm i was writing about you know this
this this last piece i was writing about
this a little bit um this sort of
shocking realization that
we
there's more room now now than there's
ever been for dissent um
[Music]
there are whole funding apparatuses for
it like you can make a living off of it
i think culture
is on the side of people pushing back
against this stuff the problem is
wokeness controls everything i mean it
is it is infected i wouldn't say
controls but it has infected every
edifice of power in the country uh you
know from the military to your local
office of you know small business
whatever the [ __ ]
to
the largest tech companies in the world
um
well at least in the largest american
tech company the world chinese tech
companies are not woke um i always
wondered this i always wonder uh i i
always used to wonder what we used to
have all we still have all these
diversity reports um that the tech press
does i'm like where's
why are we doing this for the giant
chinese tech companies why is no one why
is no one interested in that it's always
it's always just ours um or or why are
people not talking about how according
to studies i've seen the media companies
are
less diverse than the tech companies yes
yeah it's like no no one cares about
that one as much i mean people talk
about it every now and then but it
doesn't land it's like they're it's tech
that they're coming for uh but let's see
is that because money and power have
like uh kind of flowed to these tech
companies and uh it's the idea of like
they used to go after wall street uh
very aggressively because that's where
money and power is flowing now it's tech
it'll be something else i don't think
they actually believe in any of these
concepts or care about them i think that
they just don't like business these are
these are
mostly writers they're not making much
money
they
are suspicious of power which i think is
a good thing uh and suspicious of like
capitalism which i think is a bad thing
um
and their natural enemy is business
their natural enemies are the people
they cover uh they do clock us i think
correctly they clock the tech industry
correctly as very powerful and deserving
of criticism i agree with that i think
that what they're critiquing is not what
i'm critiquing they're critiquing
i'm critiquing
abuses of power in my opinion uh
specifically on social media and things
like this the censorship stuff i think
when you control
the
entire town square you
you have
i think you actually do have a
responsibility to appear american values
things like
some semblance of opens of openness and
free speech they're not critiquing stuff
like that they don't care about that
they don't they don't care about all the
control that a sensor would naturally
have um they're critiquing like the
concept of these things
uh they don't believe in that's their
problem it's like business conceptually
so that's where we part ways um
but back to wokeness i mean i mean in
terms of of like where
what's been been infected and where the
culture is all of these things have been
been infected to some degree but but the
actual
culture is just for me the
counterculture eventually becomes
culture so what is the where's the
counter culture and the counter culture
on the left and right you know bernie
bros are just as anti-woke as as most
you know uh people on the right at this
point um
it's all pushing back against the
cultural authoritarianism and that to me
is a really good sign uh it's like
those are where the strongest wins are
and so that's where
content's going to be created and that's
going to drive i think a lot of this
back i don't know how much damage has
been done at this point like what is it
reversible what's not but it does just
feel like the culture has shifted
completely is this why elon musk and
jeff bezos both have started to be much
more vocal online about yes politics and
they're kind of getting ahead of what is
perceived to be some big red wave in the
midterm elections and and culture is
shifting and so they're going to be out
in front of that to benefit today's
episode is brought to you by alto i
alright have you wanted to buy bitcoin
or over 200 other cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account well now you can
with alto ira they allow you to buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies in a
tax-advantaged way there's no account or
set up fees and it's super simple to get
started you can go today to altoira dot
com pomp to get started alto ira.com
invest in bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies altoira.com
five years ago there was no
cancel culture discourse right it was a
few people would would do something
there'd be some little bit of pushback
the reason there was no discourse was
because it actually had power like the
the wokeness was at its i think zenith
in 2017. you had a a quick flashback
that was more powerful than ever in the
summer of 2020 but
but for the most part things had changed
at that point the reason you have so
many people talking about this stuff now
is because you actually can because
america is on that side most the
majority of people
regardless of politics
don't like
paul monitors
they don't like to be told what to say
how to think uh they don't they can feel
language changing rapidly they don't
like being punished for not using the
right words they don't like people
losing their jobs forever for a tweet
like they
they
it's people don't like this [ __ ] and uh
and yeah it's it's definitely i think a
lot it's still dangerous honestly i mean
you people are losing their job still um
especially again if you're in in
entertainment or you work at a giant
tech company it is actually still
dangerous to say to speak your mind but
i think that
that has to change i think it's i think
that that has to change what about like
the use of tactics so one of the most
fascinating things uh that i've seen
play out over the last you know a couple
of months is uh on one side uh there was
a gentleman who was arrested i'll
probably get the details wrong but but
my understanding of it was a gentleman
showed up uh or was on the way to a
supreme court justice's house with i
believe a gun right and
from whatever everything i read it was
like he was going to go try to
assassinate him yeah i think he might
have turned himself in and like called
the cops
it was crazy hey i'm here i don't know
how i got here you know there was
something that happened but like
man gun supreme court justice not a good
situation yeah
and
then on the other side uh there's this
guy from texas i think he's a comedian
or maybe he's just got like some
internet show uh he's gone viral a
million times because he goes like the
local city council and he sings and he
dances he acts like an idiot i've seen
one of those viral videos he's basically
saying like this is ridiculous you're
gonna give me two minutes like i'm gonna
make a big deal about it
uh but he went to washington dc and he
was on the steps of one of the buildings
aoc is walking in and uh he basically
was yelling at her and commenting on i
think her clothes or her butt or
whatever it was right he said i think he
said
i love that
big latina ass or something whatever he
said right and so like in those two
situations like i think
you i and like 99 of people would be
like hey
in a normal society for a private
citizen like harassing them in any form
or fashion it's just like [ __ ] up
right like just leave people alone yeah
go about your life do whatever now when
it comes to
public figures right there's this whole
idea of like hey we should hold people
in power accountable we should be
suspicious of things uh and there's
probably like
what you're allowed to do and then
there's like a tasteful way of doing
things and sometimes those things
overlap and sometimes like they don't i
think threats of violence jail go
directly to jail do not collect 200
you're going to prison you're staying
there for as long as possible like i
have no tolerance for that [ __ ]
um
saying mean things to
people in power specifically elected
power
i have no sympathy for people who are
like oh my god i'm so sad they said this
mean thing you're a congresswoman and
you're like the most powerful one um i
there's no insults too horrific and i
hate that [ __ ] that was great it was
gross um but i don't care like that's
just not something that's gonna that's
gonna move
kind
uh
go through this like meandering
river thought process right is so you
have those two which i i think most
people would generally agree that like
hey words first like threats of violence
are different and whatever
then you get like i saw online there was
a tweet where somebody had taken aoc
being like the whole point of protesting
is make people uncomfortable right
right and so like if she's a hypocrite
one guy sitting there with his video
camera like yelling things which by the
way like i wouldn't say that right like
i don't think 99 of people would have
gone there and done that or said that
but like
he did okay uh there's a little like
hypocritical component but then it was
like the crown jewel which i saw you
tweeting about
was there was a protest
and a couple of congresswoman or fake
handcuffs yes
where
i saw a headline they said they got
arrested oh yeah then i saw the video
and i was like
that doesn't look like an arrest no they
they escorted her to her press
conference on a grassy little patch of
land where they were given water and
they talked to reporters that's what
happened they were not mirandized there
were no fingerprints their mug shot was
her and the squad colleagues with their
fists up smiling like that was the mug
shot it was insane and and then she
tried to say that she wasn't faking her
handcuffs
no ludicrous a ludicrous obvious lie her
hands were behind her they were like on
top of of each other she did one little
fist thing which you know the left is
saying well clearly she wasn't faking
her handcuffs because she did she put
her fists up at one point it's like yeah
because she's [ __ ] she's an idiot
that's why because she got too swept up
in the moment and put her fist up and
blew the whole thing but the the point
was for her to be photographed with her
hands behind her back and a cop next to
her so it looked like she was handcuffed
so that headline with that picture would
go viral and it did for a minute but the
internet sleuthing is a powerful thing
and the story really did become i mean
i'm not going to sit here and say that
the media won that one the story
definitely became this annoying woman
faked her handcuffs i don't think the
new york times even wrote about the
arrest that maybe they did after but
that day i checked and and they didn't
touch it and i think that that's a
pretty good indicator of of when someone
is sort of
embarrassing the establishment and she
in that moment was certainly an
embarrassment because the thought
process would be if a politician was
actually arrested it would be out on the
wires headlines it's a huge story if
ocasio was actually arrested and sent to
[ __ ] jail for being at a protest on
abortion so it's a huge deal um
it didn't happen i mean there's this we
can quibble endlessly about the
definition of arrest but
i that it's not that that's not what
happened there yeah
when you see that um does it beg the
question of like does the truth matter
or is actually the most important part
in that unfortunately just the photo and
the headline and like you score a point
and everyone moves on
you know
the idealist in me wants to say that the
truth matters
um
but
this is something i struggle with a lot
myself i i believe that you should tell
the truth
i think that
what carries the message forward
is the story so
you want to make sure that the
information you're conveying is
is accurate but you still have to tell a
compelling story and that's something
that ocasio-cortez is very good at is
telling a compelling story online trump
was really good at this and it's like
the question almost doesn't matter
because we're in the middle of an
information war and the people who are
going to win are the people who have the
most compelling story so i think maybe
it does matter but it doesn't matter
more than the story you're telling that
you have to have both i think that's
that's the important thing that you have
to reach for and if you don't have a
compelling story it doesn't matter that
you're right because you're just going
to lose
so when you look at politicians
mainstream media let's call um kind of
those in positions of power influence
whatever
there seems to be blackouts that happen
on stories um
there's like
what i'll consider less severe but still
important to call out things like andrew
yang when he was running for president
we saw the mainstream media essentially
just like we don't even know who that
guy is at one point they were putting
pictures of other people like it's all
crazy stuff
then we got the kovid and we saw like
the lab league stuff and uh i remember
the day that zero hedge got kicked off
twitter yeah and i turned to somebody
and i was like
odds just went up that's true it's like
literally that second
the lab leak was that's the craziest one
okay
it's the reason that we always go it's
that in the hundred button laptop there
there's such insane things that we can't
let them go and then sort of you always
see people in the press like yeah okay
you have your one example can you please
let it go i can't let it go because it's
it's an insane thing that happened you
have
you have a virus
coursing the planet
uh a coronavirus
and we are like hey
what's up with that [ __ ] coronavirus
factory in wuhan do we think that
perhaps it came from there and you're
banned it's like that's
the i'm not saying it definitely
happened i'm saying that is a very
reasonable question to ask it's very
reasonable to say like what's up with
that place down the block from where
you're saying the infection happened
where all the rare coronaviruses are
being studied can we maybe look into
that and the fact that we couldn't um
the fact that there were actually
consequences for looking into that for
about a year
um
no one is going to forget that anybody
who who was
concerned about that
about that lab um
only to a year later be told that
yeah you know it's it's probably you're
probably right after going through an
entire year of censorship it's like you
can't ever you can't ever look at the
media the same way again um and that was
a really important one because it was
clearly it was clearly being weaponized
you have
of and it's against our against our
national interests you have a powerful
foreign adversary
did something
potentially
like
potentially it was a potentially
existential threat to the planet um if
intentional could be considered even if
it wasn't intentional i'm saying but if
it was it would be very egregious and
like
absolutely imperative that we knew
exactly what happened and respond to
this day we need to know if if a
horrifying hell virus can be escaped
from that lab because if it can we need
to shut it down it's it's like yeah
there should be consequences for that um
and it's insane that we can't have that
conversation and now we really can't i
mean it's been years of who there's no
getting to the bottom we'll never know
the answer at this point um it was a bat
but right it was some guy eating a bat
which we were supposed to believe was
somehow less racist than the idea that
the like evil
prison state country had some evil
chernobyl-like event that led to a
catastroph like yeah like that's
obviously that's obviously what happened
like that's just obviously what happened
um
and i actually think right and this is
like the craziest part to me
let's accept that if that is what
happened
that would be a way better explanation
for almost everyone involved
right like it not intentional
it wasn't something that we don't
understand yeah but was it not
intentional
that that is a very look it's a very
important question because again it goes
back to i mean there's things that
the second and third order effects of
that entire situation including at the
time the president of the united states
shutting down flights from certain
geographic regions it led to the element
of donald trump and called racism
i mean that's really what
that
covet is why trump lost the last
election and trump was the
only person who's been hard on china for
i mean since the 70s right since before
nixon went to china there hasn't been
someone harder on china than than trump
just in terms of economics and that's
the chinese that's the preferred uh
chinese vertical of wars it's like it's
like
the economy
and the market and then like propaganda
this is how this is how we're in
conflict with china um
they wanted him out i'm not saying i
have no evidence i have no evidence it
seems like it came from the lab and it
seems a little suspicious that this
worked out so well for the nation of
china there have been zero consequences
um
and
and we weren't allowed to talk about it
because
the media also our media
that hated trump also knew that kovid
was disadvantageous to trump so if he
could find if he could be like freely
say hey
it seems like it came from this country
america we would have been outraged um
that would have been the story it would
have been a much more important story
than just trump's clownish incompetence
handling a pandemic that then nobody
else handled if you look at um
past historical events nothing unites a
country more than war
and
there have been arguments that some
people even gone to war to unite the
country for political gain and all this
type of stuff
if the media had treated
that situation 180 degrees difference
there's a very strong argument that the
country would have been heavily united
on this
front of we have to address the
situation
there's leadership and actually would
have won by an absolute landslide yeah
how do you have a serious conversation
about the problematic use of the word
spazz when an aggressive nuclear
superpower is trying to destroy your
entire population
it's impossible like all this divisive
[ __ ] is just impossible in a in a world
like that i think war is bad and we want
to stay out of it and increasingly we
want to
i mean
i think probably best case scenario
after world war ii as america would have
just been in charge of everything um
but we didn't do that we tried to sort
of police the seas and do this free
trade thing
we allowed power to
grow in places like china and russia now
increasingly we're in a multi-polar
nuclear
world
and
sort of geography's thawing again
history is beginning again and
uh we're gonna have to i think retreat a
little bit and just
fortify our borders and uh bring
manufacturing home things like this
that's gonna take time uh
but also i mean
like this taiwan thing
i
got in a lot of trouble among right-wing
people um what did you say
so among the populists right right now
it's like they're america first that's
their whole thing if something is not in
america's interest then we shouldn't be
doing it and i agree that's i 100 agree
that's my politics i it's we should this
country should come first it's i don't
want a single politician in washington
who doesn't think that america should
come first that's their job
but when it comes to things like taiwan
this is this is then used as a reason to
not be involved in the sort of china
taiwan conflict at all
and that's ridiculous because
what happens to taiwan affects america
we need semiconductors like with without
we will have years of no electron no new
electronics
potentially that is the world that we're
we're walking towards without
a free taiwan uh and that is just a
product of that's that's what happens
after you know decades of globalism
where we've exported all of our
manufacturing and left ourselves
completely vulnerable things that i
write about all the time our resource
and security our manufacturing and
security we do need these industries at
home not because it's like just because
it's oh bring the jobs home it's not
it's just it's also it's a huge national
security issue to be so resource and
secure but also there's there's no
short-term way to snap your fingers and
start processing rare earth metals
across the country it doesn't work that
way it takes time to build this stuff up
and until it does we are at the mercy of
these global supply chains which we kind
of have to protect and so i think it's a
balance i think it's like
yeah you don't you're not going abroad
because it's like oh it just makes me
sad that the taiwanese are going to be
invaded by china it's like this is we
are affected by all of this and so we
kind of have to keep things as steady as
we can until we can build our strength
back up um
and so why did they get mad why did who
give other right-wing people they don't
there's like oh you love war you want to
go and you want to go and send our boys
abroad to die on the shores of taiwan
for semiconductors and it's like first
of all i don't think that we even need
to fire i don't think we need to even
send anybody over there uh they said
nancy
yeah
pelosi
she bought it fixed the problem look at
that look at that maverick
flying over there you saw the movie i've
seen the memes
i live in the memes i mean yeah like
it's pretty good though
like uh i also think it's uh wild that
uh many of the chinese state talking
points i've gotten from uh chinese state
twitter accounts
yeah and it's like
wait a minute yeah they're like they're
all there alex jones isn't but we've got
literal chinese assets telling us the
news
yeah
it's just kind of crazy right like we
don't have
you know you take one into the spectrum
of alex jones take another end of like a
politician a donald trump you've got
plenty of other people in various other
corners of the internet whatever that
aren't on twitter anymore uh
but like there are accounts that
literally are labeled chinese like state
affiliated media yeah you're like
okay i wonder if the strategy there
because it seems like i mean obviously
you think on the one hand like this
definitely shouldn't be on twitter but
then
is the strategy
like if we let them post openly then
they won't create a bunch of fake
accounts that are even more difficult to
keep track of i'm not advocating to take
them down right like cool i like that
they label it like i get it leave them
but the argument i think i'm making is
like
i mean you would have to be so egregious
short of
inciting violence
why are they on and other people aren't
right right like it's more it's less
about like hey ban more people kick more
people off
more like
more people on the platform yeah martin
shkreli member yeah so
yeah martin was banned
because he went after
when after
lauren duka who is no longer on the
internet we forget about she was like
she was she was the taylor lorenz before
taylor lorenz um she was
the last like sort of
main character of the deranged left and
uh she worked for
teen vogue and was on like tucker
carlson and stuff like this um
always just sort of
making the craziest possible cases that
were new to america and we were like
whoa this is like a crazy thing to say
about um the reduction of us to our
gender or our race and uh she was
talking about things like systemic white
supremacy back
before that was a normal thing to say
really i mean people forget but white
supremacy used to mean kkk like five
years ago and now it's just like i mean
your mailman's a white supremacist
everyone's a white supremacist that's
that's a new thing that happened uh but
she was a sort of uh pioneer in the
space of deranged woke [ __ ] and um
she got into it with shkreli i don't
even know of her what but he started
asking her on dates and he just was like
i think he might even ask her to a dance
or something but it was like very
innocent but persistent and she said
this was harassment and uh and he was
banned from the platform for it and i i
went back and looked at it because um he
got out of prison
recently and i was curious about why he
had been banned because he was creating
new accounts and they kept removing him
they're like no you're permanently
banned um so i went back and i saw it
and it was that and that was just given
crazy hindsight bias did it seem crazy
no i well again it's another sign of the
fact that culture has
shifted um
this was you know in 2017 or something
when he was kicked off it was it was
i think things are i do think things are
better right now which is a crazy thing
to say but i think that culturally i
really believe that things are are
are much better he's still permanently
banned but i don't know that someone
would get banned who knows watch me get
banned for this i don't even know um but
i i think in general
things are better
uh
that haven't been said yeah like why are
these chinese assets tweeting while you
know alex jones is still off the
platform
when it comes to all these banning
decisions uh we had one incident where
uh we had a video we were interviewing
somebody uh a student anonymous person
he's talking about bitcoin stuff
whatever and uh
all of a sudden i got like an email
an email and then not just like
hey that video was taken down like the
entire youtube channel was deleted i
think i i remember this what what and i
remember at first just being like uh
give it five minutes you know like turn
your computer off turn it back on maybe
it'll like reappear and then it like
took like i'm fixing 20 minutes i was
like holy [ __ ] like
the channel's gone or just being like at
the end of the day like does it really
matter right like in the sense of like
it's not like somebody came and like
shot me
but like no but it's great you've built
a whole world there a whole audience a
whole thing like all stuff so luckily i
had other platforms like twitter where i
could go and tweet and be like yo what
the [ __ ] right and tag youtube and like
do all this stuff and everything and uh
of course if you have a big following
like there's people who work at youtube
who follow you yeah like dming you being
like can you give me some details let me
just look into it whatever it's like
thank you that's super helpful
but then like i don't know
six hours later whatever it was like it
gets reinstated and uh there's like an
email and it was like basically like uh
it's back right like essentially like
just like like
here you go peasant like you you can now
have your toy back right like all right
thanks guys uh
and i remember i asked uh i think it was
an employee there
and i said uh what happened
and the answer gave me the like vibe
that it was like one employee
at the company
who had the power to do it was like [ __ ]
this guy
literally right and uh because normally
the way that it works is like you get a
strike you get a second strike right
there's a third strike then you're done
like what also so like there's a process
which i i agree with like they try to
warn people they they try to have a uh
dialogue whatever and you may disagree
with some of the decisions they make or
whatever but it's not like you just wake
up one day and bam it's gone short of
again inciting violence or whatever
but i was like holy [ __ ]
how many people at that company have the
power to like press a button how many
people delete it how many people have
been erased how many people have been
erased who don't have your platform and
i think it happens all the time uh or it
has i i don't
i don't it's all mistakes
yeah
it is misinterpreted hugely
like when they become like big loud
stories for sure
um
yeah i mean it's messed up at the end of
the day you don't own your audience this
is why i mean i prefer things like sub
stack where or any email newsletter
where you where you least have the
audience um you know i don't you can't
even you know i have however many
twitter followers i can't even i can't
even dm them all
right like i don't they're not they're
not actually my audience if you don't
have any meaningful ability to
communicate with them directly you can't
take them anywhere either yeah no yeah
they're just there um another story you
mentioned earlier uh the president of
the united states
his son
as the memes would suggest every time
that he wants to hang out with
prostitutes do drugs uh pretty much like
just live his life
he puts like 17 cameras on his head yeah
right and films everything
yeah i mean he loves it
if this was a reality television show it
would be the number one show in america
we would be like holy [ __ ]
like how did they get prostitutes on
television how did they get hard drug
usage like all this [ __ ] it'd be like
cops when we were all growing up and
like you would watch and be like i
wonder if the guy's gonna run away
combined with like the [ __ ]
awesomeness of the internet in one show
and like it would be the the the number
one show in america
but it's not a show yeah yeah it's real
but no one really talks about it in the
mainstream i think
yeah i mean
i've noticed the new york times
doing
i mean they did a piece on the hundred
biden they were the ones so the
washington post
back when the hunter biden laptop story
a month before the last presidential
election was uh
put out by the new york post
so near post gets this laptop
from some repair guy
who like handed it off to i think i
forget i forget like the chain of events
somehow rudy giuliani that it gets to
rudy giuliani and then like the post is
writing about the contents of it um so
this this explosive thing is coming out
these are the first this is like you
know in the sort of maybe trilogy of
hunter biden sex tapes this is like this
is the first one this is the fellowship
of the ring um fellowship of the [ __ ]
ring it's like it's right there that's
where it begins so
uh
the near folks released the story
and uh
it's
censored across the entire social the
social internet it didn't sound like a
crazy enough story where you're like
that was crazy real it was crazy and
what you had is you had a series of
people in the intelligence community not
directly working for uh
us intelligence anymore but they have
been so they're in the intelligence
community and they go to the social
media people they're like yo this is
russian misinformation disinformation
and it's like what is like is is the
laptop leaked like did they is it is the
video now they make the video like
what is what is fake exactly here um
doesn't matter all banned uh
it what really got crazy was actually
how you couldn't even on messenger you
could not even dm the story to someone
you couldn't share the link to the story
uh twitter as well on twitter was the
worst one facebook everything was just
the virality was slowed down so they
just slowed down the story until
uh a third party
independent fact checker could verify or
not the claims which of course i mean
we've never heard back from that review
ever this is years ago and we've not
heard back from the third party review
they're still doing the work yeah
they're still checking it out uh so this
happens it's of course all real the
washington post is
at the moment
the official fact check on the new york
post story
and
uh
the new york times if you look at a side
by side
the new york times was much more like
we don't really know uh yeah i mean we
have no information that it's not real
here's what's happening here's what the
york post is saying we have no idea
whereas the washington post was like
we don't like what this implies because
the new york uh the said the new york
the washington post the washington post
fact check was like we don't like what
this implies the headline of the new
york post which broke the story said it
was a smoking gun of corruption so
what what was actually being
fact-checked was just the opinion they
didn't like the what the washington post
didn't like was what the new york post
was saying this probably meant and uh
and so then the story was widely
censored but it was the new york times
that then kicked the ball forward a
little bit later like a year
or so later i think uh
they verified all of the claims they
were the ones who broke it and everyone
was like oh whoops guess it was real uh
and like no harm no foul right guys kind
of moving forward
um
and they're the ones who who seem to be
inching forward with uh hunter biden
corruption story still like they're
still very much a team it looks like to
me that's on top of this story and it
has to do with burisma which is this
ukrainian energy company that hunter was
on the board of and it's like did
he
use his father's influence
at the time of the barack obama
presidency to gain favor and all this
[ __ ] that they're they seem to be on so
people do seem to be following the story
does anyone in the world believe
that
the
children
of the president or vice president of
the united states of america does not
get treated differently
whether it is crossing the street
whether it's in business whether it's
literally standing in line to order sure
well it's like i mean the reason that
the sex tapes and the sort of like
crack saga is so important is
because it's like
why would you want this guy on your bo
why are you paying this guy 500 000 a
year to be on your board he's a drug
addict addicted to filming himself
having sex with prostitutes it's like
well i don't even know what his
qualification what are his
qualifications well i would love to sit
down with the burisma execs and be like
what do you like about hunter
what are you what are you getting from
this has anybody interviewed them yet uh
i have i you know what i haven't seen
that interview i would love to i mean if
maybe one of you would be fast one of
your listeners can link me i would be i
would love it the the um the other piece
of it too uh
is if that's all on his laptop like
where are other things right like the
internet is a place where like you only
got to press a button to send shits to
other people other places and so i think
there's this element of like
hey there's some crazy stuff here right
and like
yeah do i really care that you do crack
cocaine uh and like there's an argument
we should get you some help right like
there's like a sad like humanity well
the conspiracy is that
no i don't tell me the humanity thing i
no no just like
if if you're
uh aware of somebody who's addicted to
hard drugs right like there's two
responses like that's [ __ ] up and then
also like hey we should probably get
that person some help and so there is
this element of like okay if the
president of the united states
son
is addicted to crack cocaine like
some portion of people whether it's
small or large is like
did we get him help like like can we
help the guy out i felt bad for him
during the election before i knew about
the barista stuff so then this is where
when you add in the the context of
everything i leave this guy alone i
don't care about the sun's not running
for the president like why are we
talking about this and then i learned a
little more and i was like
this person's very close to power and
money and uh and this is it i mean it
there's a lot of smoke in this story
it's like i i don't think there's yet
any real
fire corruption fire but there's smoke
and what do you think would be like the
smoking
this episode is brought to you by ledger
the best crypto hardware wallet
everyone's heard the phrase not your
keys not your coins and that's more true
today than it's ever been
ultimately a value proposition of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies is
self-custody where you get to retain
ownership over your digital assets that
is what ledger specializes in they've
got multiple pieces of hardware and they
also have the ledger live mobile app
which makes it seamless to not only
retain control over your bitcoin but
also allows you to interface with
exchanges lending platforms and other
types of software products if you're
interested in upping your self-custody
game go check out ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self custody you'll thank me
later
they need to know if
biden
offered
anything so like if the president is
directly involved then all of a sudden
that's like the vice president yeah
because he was the vice president of the
time so but if it's a step away even if
it's uh i'll call it um a gray area
questionable then you think that's
already like it's already pr it's
already pretty bad and i think that uh
so the conspiracy
about giving me the most extreme
conspiracy theory well that the deep
state has leaked the videos because they
want to remove biden from power because
he's going to lose the next election so
you have to weaken him so you can
primary him you have to justify the
primary you know it's like oh yeah we're
constantly seeing him now with his his
gaffes he's like looking dumber by the
day is that because he is more senile
than he was when he ran for the last
election or is it because people are
putting more of a of a spotlight on it
and like who is doing that that's the
that's you have the the media and the
people around the dubai administration
but then this footage is is released in
waves
increasingly drawing scrutiny uh over
the 100 biden crush the hunter biden
corruption story and you are really in a
place now where i mean
it does seem like he's going to be i if
i were
you know a card-carrying member of the
democratic party just obsessed with
partisan politics i would want him gone
i would want to for sure i would want
him there's no way he's going to win
then i don't see him winning the next
election i don't i don't as of the
information we have at the moment uh it
looks bleak
for both the midterm election and also
uh if he was to run again and it was
good back to me also like
why do any of these 70 and 80 year old
people want to be the president of the
united states why are they allowed to be
the president of the united states like
honestly can we just have a cut it
should be just the age of retirement
that's the cut-off but if we're not
going to do that then i think at least
80. i think 80
is like a fair
cut-off point for all of them it begs
the question should it be an age cut off
or should there be like a cognitive test
should there be a uh
some sort of disqualifying medical
evaluation right and i don't say it from
like uh you know i see the memes i see
it i
see the speeches like there are times
where uh there are maybe gaffes is like
the the nicest way to put it um
but like if you or i wanted to go become
a navy seal
they would put us through immense
physical and mental training and
evaluation
to then send us
to faraway lands yeah to support the
united states of america the problem is
how this test is going to be weaponized
um you have
pretty much one party that
in america i think that you have one
party you have one sort of
ethos
worldview
kind of class that controls
you know every seat of government it
controls
the tech the media academia
and um and certainly all of the
bureaucratic seats like the whole san
francisco government for example like
you can
change over the government there are a
handful of supervisors that you could
vote in you could change the way
government looks uh you could change
your legislator
your legislators but what you can't
change are all the people who work for
the san francisco government and they
are just
they're all the same kind of like
um
useless
bureaucratic like the hall monitor
energy is what you get and they're
they're everywhere um and so like those
people all vote the same way and
that test there's there's like almost no
way it's not going to be weaponized in
my opinion so i i think an age cut-off
would be would be cleaner this one yeah
all right uh
as we watch
kind of the world unfold uh we've talked
about a lot of pessimistic things
what's like the optimistic argument as
to like how america at a minimum holds
on
at a maximum
has this like renaissance and uh
continues to accelerate as the greatest
country in the world well i think
america's biggest problem is that it's
so easy to succeed here like we have a
lot of room to fail and we're still
thriving and that has to do with
uh our ice our relative geographical
isolation
uh our abundant natural resources and
all of the wealth that we're standing on
top of over the fro from you know the
last decades and decades so
because of that it's
we allow things to get to get pretty bad
and uh
so i i don't know i don't see us
i don't see
long term i i see us
it's almost impossible for us
to
enter a world of sorry dark ages status
i think we're going to be
limping along for a while um
the question is whether or not we become
great and
and that is all that depends on culture
so that's why i care so much about
culture that's why i write about culture
that's why i
try and make
other people care about this stuff
because that's that that becomes who we
are the stories we consume the things
that we want to be
is what determines the shape of our
world and uh we're in a really great
position actually we could be
you know the greatest
we already are i think the greatest
country in the history of the world but
i mean we could be great in ways that
are inconceivable right now and um
[Music]
i
what do we have to do like we're
back-to-back world war champs
right yeah uh i don't think we want to
go fight another i think we have to care
about local politics honestly okay
explain i think that
we have really abandoned
like basic [ __ ] just
we have internalized the sense that
we're not in charge of our of the world
around us that we're not responsible for
the world around us our own lives like
this
the way that this manifests is in every
city i've i drove at the beginning of
the pandemic or the fall after the
pandemic began i drove cross country and
i was looking for another place to live
maybe i didn't know where i was going to
be
every city i went to had a homeless
problem every city i went to had a drug
problem every city i went to was covered
in trash like every city i went to had a
public education problem had a public
infrastructure problem it i was living
in san francisco and in san francisco
there are a lot of like sort of
influencer-type people with big
megaphones and so we know a lot about
what's going on in san francisco and it
is crazy and i do think san francisco is
kind of uniquely crazy there are it's
like almost a fun city to tell stories
about because the people are
the politicians are so deranged i mean
you had an actual pro-crime d.a who was
just recalled like it's a fun story to
tell it's like it's crazy but the
problem the problems are everywhere that
we have a problem of smart people
not
engaging where they are people feeling
intransient uh i think is that the right
word in transient or when you're
uprooted and
just transient it's like you have a
transience of people kind of moving from
city to city smart people specifically
um a lack of loyalty to where you're
from uh
and that
when that kind of i think
that that becomes
the way that we engage with the entire
world is is just
someone else will do it someone else
will work on this why is it like this
i'm going to just be mad about it and
then let it go or not be mad at that's
even worse if you just kind of
internalize a sense that uh you know a
homeless drug addict
going to the bathroom on your front
steps is normal that's just the cost of
living in san francisco like once you
internalize that that's the end i mean
you're never gonna fix anything if you
just think that that's normal and and
feel bad for criticizing it um so i
think you start there you have to start
with your home you have to you have to
make where you physically are
right now um a better place and
and i think that if we can we can start
doing that i mean we have people in the
tech industry talking about charter city
stuff and we're going to build a new
country that's how i got into tech was
the c-setting institute this whole cool
ideological um
idealistic
uh
thought experiment really about what
would it look like if we could build a
sort of host of uh politically
autonomous cities in the middle of the
ocean and you know rebuild everything
from scratch that's all exciting and i
is it possible so yes i think so i think
it's all possible but
but actually like the path to change is
just unfortunately caring about the five
idiots on your board of supervisors who
have
legalized crime like you could just you
could just focus on that problem and
vote them out and fix things and um
you know you don't have to reinvent the
city you have to just care about the
city that you're in and i for some
reason
like people just
don't do that um i saw the new uh was
san francisco d.a i think came in yeah
and uh real radical ideas like we're
gonna put people in jail if they commit
crimes she's saying i like what she's
saying i like what she will see we'll
see
what she does um but yeah i mean it
feels good just to have someone not
gaslight you and say like yeah like
if someone throws a brick through your
window that's a problem
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for saying that to me already a step
ahead
uh last thing i want to talk about is uh
the state of the media with pirate wires
uh i think you've got like pretty big
ambitions in terms of like how do you uh
create
content and allow people to consume
things stuff that are like the signal
among the noise or like the pirate ship
among like the chaos like yeah
why do we need independent media
well i think everything is
independent media at this point even
people who work for the establishment
increasingly have their own substance or
whatever their own channels their own
presences on social media they're
becoming they're independent in a sense
um that's just identity
your personal identity is really
powerful now because of social media and
and that's the future landscape of media
new york times is this big outlier
where it's it's definitely a brand first
and then writer second and they've i
think fired the one person who was like
sort of
fighting against this trend internally
um
but in a very public way and who's and
she happens to be very obsessed with
with brand and social media and things
like this uh
the new york times is is the outlier the
general trend are its people online
talking who we like and uh and maybe it
will be a collection of them it'll be
like a handful of people and a crew uh
in a group in in uh in you know maybe in
our small army um but it's it's always
going to be people that's the future and
that's
what firewall i mean i want as i grow i
want to bring in more people and have
just like a handful of
people who you can
trust so also when they get things wrong
just admit it and be like oh i was wrong
about that and and tell people i want to
build i think in all of this
chaos
um
information cast like i mean i love a
good fight
online but also
like it's funny a lot of it's funny and
i just formative i just like
i can't help but laugh at the craziest
[ __ ] and i want to build a place i
basically just want pirate wires is just
i'm building the place that i wish
existed
online a a place in the media landscape
where i can go and just like laugh at
the [ __ ] and kind of try and piece
together the facts of what's happening
and and get a a
more accurate sense of of what's going
on someone to help sort of like parse
the news um yeah that's that's what it
is that's the future and it starts there
she's going to grow uh
through i'm going to hire more writers
and we're going to grow it and um take
it sort of day by day
how do you replicate the magics like
i've told you in private like every time
you write i'm just like you just don't
miss right like just every time i read
it i'm like either this is laugh out
loud funny
this is like so spot on or like holy
[ __ ] i should text him and make sure
that like he's still okay because
they're gonna definitely come for him
right it's like one of those things
sometimes all three together but like
there is uh a unique combination of uh
one you see what's happening you're able
to kind of pick out uh what are the
important parts you can connect them to
like tom cruise and other things that
are happening in today's society and
like how they all kind of fit together
in a narrative uh you have a very unique
way of writing which i think people uh
really enjoy consuming but like each one
of those things is hard by itself like
you're a unique person how do you
replicate that uh with other people that
you would bring on i think that you
don't i i think that what you want to do
is first of all like
i don't really believe in
diversity of thought like in the way
that it's used people talk about uh the
real diversity you need is diversity of
opinion and it's like maybe i mean not
on the big stuff though like in terms of
values i don't believe in diversity i
believe that we are it's like we're
thickest thieves we're on the same side
we want the same thing we're completely
mission oriented that's actually the
place where where you that's the
diversity in every other aspect go for
it
this
no like i think that you you want a
shared perspective i want to work with
people who
don't necessarily see
they don't think the way i do but they
kind of have the same impulses that i do
they're like they're they want the same
things and like generally for the
country and for their communities and
they kind of agree on the [ __ ] um
it's like once you have that much in
common then it's about finding people
who have their own strengths and
nurturing them and
i think that's the that's that's
it's gonna be like the x-men where it's
not not everyone wearing the same
costume and having the same power it's a
collection of people who do a bunch of
extraordinary things and together you're
fighting the sort of you're fighting the
fight what does success look like like
do you take down the patriarchy or like
what like what is the what is the thing
that you're like yeah we are the
patriarchy i'm the p i am i'm the
treasurer of the patriarchy nice to meet
you
uh
i
i want to be i mean we're going to build
the biggest media company in the world
and it just is where it starts that
someone is going to this is like the
media has completely changed
the old model is dead it's what you're
seeing now is not even the old model
it's just the
empty carcass
of what once existed it's like we're
roaming the museums
of
our cities even feel like museums of a
world that once was certainly our media
entities right now these big media
properties they're not alive anymore
they're not they're they're not they're
it's just people have people are working
there and kind of keeping the lights on
but that's gone the next thing is going
to be it's going to be a person who's
going to become very big and then
grow the company
around them um and
there are all sorts of people who are
trying to do something like that
everyone kind of knows that that's the
future
roughly um are there other ones that
you're impressed by or that you think
are doing it right
that you point you're like oh like they
get it
there are lots of people i have a lot of
respect for uh
i think so i really like um
strategy uh i really like
uh
i really like barry wiese
um
i think that
you have people like tybee and greenwald
who are huge but not
doing as much with that it's like
they're still
they're just right they just have big
audiences that's different it's like
what what do you do to expand and um
like if you're glenn greenwald what do
you think he should do to double or
triple well i think he's probably in a
confused place right now because he's
he started with a company and now he's
his own person and that seems better and
more flexible and maybe he just doesn't
have the ambition to build like an
empire
i think that if you are
i think the mistake you would make
while building something off of your
back would be to hire a bunch of people
who are nothing like you
i think you want to hire people who
amplify your voice first um because
that's what's working and then
find talented people who are doing their
own thing but care about the same thing
and and kind of have the same
vibe
roughly speaking and i think that's the
way that you build it i think that the
mistake a lot of people are making right
now is trying to like rebuild
the old
model that's not working and what you
can't do online
is anything that sacrifices your voice
because in a world with so much writing
and so much media we live inside of it
everything sounds the same mediocrity
has the same voice and
what what stands out are people who have
a unique voice and that's the only thing
that matters now um everyone successful
has that and uh and some are better than
a few or the best
and um
you want to just feed that you want to
feed that originality because people
they are looking for that
in the way that
they know that the thing that exists
right now is wrong and so they don't
want
they know that
and so they know that the truth
is going to sound different like it'll
look different it will sound different
it's going to stand out and people are
going to make fun of it um you know
people people in the establishment are
going to make fun of i could throw eggs
at it look at this clown talking in a
funny way or whatever else but
necessarily like the new thing has to be
fundamentally different so people will
look for that and when you find it you
have to nurture it
when you take that idea of the media uh
it overlaps really well with a lot of
these folks who are now becoming
politicians or who have been politicians
obviously trump was the quintessential
example um but i think as people look
forward to 2024 it's like
trump
biden desantis newsom yeah those seem to
be like again i don't pay a ton of
attention to politics but if you said to
me pick the four people who are like
most likely to run and have a shot it
seems like those four are the names that
you keep hearing uh but now post trump
feels like there's always gonna be like
the wild card and like i've always said
like i think the rock will be president
one day yeah super charismatic well
known you know all this type of stuff
physically just
massive compared to everyone else and
some kind of human biologies like i
guess that guy's the leader right all
that type of stuff um
but like how do you think that all plays
out and you know
it's almost kind of like when you're a
kid you're like would you rather you
know uh do this or do that you come with
the most ridiculous things you come up
with like now it's like do you think
that trump without a twitter account
versus biden you know at 80 like who
wins
it's like how do you see this playing
out i always just bet on the best story
and that's
newsom versus desantis
it's a battle of florida versus
california and we have a real national
conversation on the differences between
those two states
i
in
in my gut i think trump's not going
anywhere
but i think i think i think i'm
this is not the way that i'm not good at
these kinds of predictions
because i go off of just
intuition
and i just i think that that's
i think it's desantis newsome
which is crazy because it means trump is
gone and biden's gone it's the weirdest
one i think in in a sense but i think
it's the most rational i think it's the
most it's just the one that people i
think it's the conversation that people
want to have yeah it goes back to again
like i'm joking but i'm not right like
trump without a twitter account is not
trump right because like part of the
entertainment value and also part of the
effectiveness and also part of the like
stoking the critics and the haters and
you know whatever other i think he said
the haters the losers and the critics or
like whatever he said right like
all of that was his central hub has not
been taken away so it's kind of like you
know if you said to an mma fighter like
get in the boxing ring right like you're
not a kick wrestle like you're like all
right well like maybe they got a shot
but yeah probably not as effective
and then biden i actually think uh age
is like a huge huge component i think
the democrats never intended on running
him again and then
no one stepped up and so for a minute it
was like well he's gonna run again and
it's just clearly i think there's it's
if he does it will be the end yeah so
you you get desantis and newsome and uh
i think that they also believe that
because knew some struggle oh they run
ads in florida yeah desantis has you
know got the disney thing like you can
see them almost jockeying to kind of set
the stage for this like i don't know
okay corral 12 noon like let's draw
pistols and see you know who's quicker
um
it's also i mean it's so far out
anything could happen between now and
then yeah of course but right now that's
where
the
i think that's where all of the energy
is descent is for sure listen trump is
powerful and i mean he is just he's like
king making right now in seats across
the country so it's hard to say that
he's
he's lost
his mojo
um
but how does he communicate to the
people like like to me you're whole
thing of like the story
the story is really important but
distribution of the story is also yeah
it's gonna be hard for him without it
without a channel i think that uh
because it's not like hey they'll give
it back to him from what we understand
right now no i mean that would be a
curveball of an event if all of a sudden
twitter was like cool if you're running
for president you can have it back
like
you thought there was uproar when you
got kicked off
imagine the uproar they gave they
brought them back to run for president
we'll see what'll happen i mean at the
end of the day they might just want the
growth because trump wherever he goes is
a huge draw for crowds and
to a certain extent he kind of i mean he
kind of invented twitter in its most
recent incar this current incarnation is
it's his platform it's it's he's the one
who who drew all the attention and and
made twitter what it is today in in a
sense um they might just want it that
badly
or elon's forced to buy it he might be
forced i mean i kind of
i know he doesn't want to buy it and i
feel like he's going he has a lot on his
plate i understand that but i selfishly
want him to be forced to buy it
yeah
i mean can you imagine uh yeah
i live in these fantasies within a week
of him owning it
even if nothing
like nothing no nothing he's gonna
appoint me to ceo he thinks i'm gonna
slide into his dms
i'm gonna tell him i'm ready to step up
and serve my country
and he's gonna be like go for it i i
think um uh uh there would be a shift in
energy on the platform to the point
where people would be like the internet
is fun again
like
elon is here i think that is
the most important thing and
people
are just done being miserable
and that is the most compelling
part of i think what elon is and what
trump was that people refused to see and
in general what things
the things that that really land online
it's like
i think people are looking
to move past these pa these this last
handful of years of of kind of just like
intensity and find the levity it's like
a pressure release it's going to allow
us
to just breathe and
move forward and i agree with you 100
yeah um
[Music]
it also begs a question i guess uh
did you get is it a subpoena
were you were you dragged into i saw i
heard that it's the new midas list yeah
so explain first of all what's going on
so people know about but it seems like i
mean what i've read online is twitter
leadership is uh has subpoenaed a bunch
of people in elon's orbit just i have no
idea why just be because of the lawsuit
they're trying to bring them in maybe
piece this the whole wild story together
um i'm waiting because aren't do is this
the kind of thing that's like you've
been served is they like they find you
outside or something and
and call your name i think if you're
like a a billionaire or you're you know
i mean or a fake billionaire fake
billionaire the circle of people that
they have brought into this are
literally the best investors in the
world yeah so like the whole idea of the
new midas list okay uh i don't think
that they like track you down on the
street i think it's more of like a
they call a lawyer and they're like hey
we can come do the on the street thing
but like i want it we are going to make
it very very different i want the whole
thing i want i want the the real
treatment i want to be served mike's
hannah
and it would be i would love to jump i
would love i would love to tweet about
this there's a thing i would love to i
would love it it is take a picture with
it on the ground it is
list i mean everybody wants to be on
this list it is the the hottest new
status symbol in silicon valley is a
subpoena in the twitter elon lawsuit and
i'm waiting for
mine all right where can we send people
to pirates piratewires.com uh i tweeted
uh mick selana mic solana sol a a um
and
this is where you can find me
thank you so much thank you